Вулиця Шпитальна, 6.
Ні, вулиця Шпитальна, 17.
Я перепрошую.
[англійською] Учора зі мною разом у ліфті їхала жінка,
і я привітався: «Добрий вечір!». Вона спитала:
[англійською] «Ви спілкуєтеся українською?»
І я їй кажу: «Гарного дня!», а вона мені: «Окей».
[сміється]
[англійською] Зазвичай люди дуже дивуються,
коли я починаю говорити спонтанно...
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[англійською] Моя мама підійшла до мене і сказала:
[англійською] «У мене є подруга в Україні, її син там.
Ти можеш поїхати навчатися туди».
[англійською] Не буду брехати, я нічогісінько не знав про Україну, тож я загуглив і подумав: «Окей, добре, погнали!»
[англійською] Я вивчав фармацевтику.
[англійською] Упродовж навчання
ми були єдиною іноземною групою на фармацевтиці.
[англійською] Перше, що зробив, — купив гітару.
Я зовсім трішечки займався музикою.
[англійською] Мабуть, на останньому році навчання у школі.
[англійською] Після випуску зі школи я не пробув
удома навіть і місяця і приїхав в Україну.
[англійською] Одразу після школи я зібрався й поїхав.
[англійською] Тож я купив гітару,
вчився грати завдяки Youtube.
[англійською] Деякий час я грав
у центрі з незнайомцями, як не смішно, до речі.
[англійською] Я знайомився з ними
і питався — для них ніхто не співав.
[англійською] «Окей, може ви би хотіли, щоб я співав?
Я розмовляю українською». Вони казали: «Окей, круто!»
[англійською] І так ми просто собі грали
в центрі, але нічого особливого.
[англійською] Нічого особливого не було доти,
доки ми з Андрієм не почали писати власну музику.
[наспівує]
— Куди їхати?
— Шпитальна, 17, будь ласка.
[англійською] Я приїхала в Україну вчитися.
[англійською] Дитина маминої подруги вчилася тут,
у Тернополі, у медичному університеті,
[англійською] тож вона порадила його моїй мамі.
[англійською] Було занадто холодно.
І було занадто тихо, занадто тихо для мене.
[англійською] Було занадто холодно і занадто тихо.
Але, знаєте, з часом я до цього звикла.
[англійською] Я жила не сама, а з африканцями.
Я всюди ходила за ними слідом і все розпитувала.
[англійською] Іноді, коли я хотіла під'їхати автобусом,
я мусила телефонувати їм і питати:
[англійською] «У який автобус мені сідати?»
І вони мені допомагали.
[англійською] Раніше треба було ходити на заняття,
ми одягалися, йшли в університет, поверталися.
[англійською] Але зараз через COVID-19 ми всі
сидимо вдома й мусимо все робити самі.
[англійською] Бо, знаєте, коли ми ходили на заняття,
викладачі мусили нам усе пояснювати, а зараз...
[англійською] Вони просто надсилають
письмові матеріали, і ми маємо читати
[англійською] й пояснювати це самі собі,
щоб усе зрозуміти.
[англійською] Чесно, зараз важко.
Але ми маємо звикнути і пройти через це.
[англійською] Я вже два роки вчу українську,
але досі не можу спілкуватися, бо це дуже важко.
[англійською] У Нігерії багато мов. Це не так,
як в Україні, де всі говорять однією мовою.
[англійською] У нас справді багато мов.
[англійською] Отже, ти можеш бути з Нігерії,
я можу бути з Нігерії, але ми можемо не порозумітися.
[англійською] Також ми маємо загальну мову — піджин.
Це як «поламана» англійська.
[англійською] Студія — там.
[англійською] У мене був вибір між російською та українською.
Але мені не сподобалося, як звучала російська мова.
[англійською] Мене питали: «Чому українська?»
А я казав: «Бо я в Україні, ось чому!»
[англійською] Я не бачив сенсу вчити російську.
[англійською] Я якось постійно притягую до себе українців,
які розмовляють англійською.
[англійською] Я слухав, як спілкуються
інші люди і копіював звідти.
[англійською] Вибач, у мене мокрі руки.
— [англійською] Привіт! Радий тебе знову бачити.
— [англійською] Клас!
— Зробити вам кави, пацани?
— Я би чайку випив. Якщо є.
— Чорний, зелений?
— Давай зелений!
— [англійською] Джефрі, кави, чаю?
— [англійською] Зеленого чаю!
[англійською] Дякую!
А де ми познайомилися?
[англійською] Я навіть точно не пам'ятаю. Було дуже людно.
[англійською] Здається, тоді ми просто
обмінялися номерами телефонів.
Так, обмінялися телефонними номерами.
[англійською] Чесно, я не знаю, як воно було.
Просто я набрав, сказав:
«Привіт, ми до тебе прийдемо в гості!»
Прийшли в гості. Ось і всьо! Всьо просто!
Я перший раз вас почув,
коли ви грали в «Бункермузі» в Тернополі.
— О, це було дуже давно.
— Це було дуже давно ...
Пам'ятаю, компанія снобів, з якими я приходив,
така була: «О, шо це типу за музон?»
А я прийшов такий:
«О, клас-клас, я вриваюся по-любому!».
[англійською] Тож зазвичай я перевіряю, чи маю замовлення, через телефон. І тоді я доставляю їх своєчасно.
[англійською] Я просто шукала, що робити.
[англійською] Зазвичай тутешні люди,
здебільшого африканці, воліють куховарити.
[англійською] Мені навіть здалося,
що всі вміють куховарити.
[англійською] Я хотіла займатися чимось іншим.
[англійською] І я натрапила на одну жінку в Instagram.
[англійською] Але вона працює в Штатах і робить блиск для губ.
[англійською] Мені це сподобалося,
тож і я вирішила цим займатися.
[англійською] Спочатку, коли я починала, я не знала, що і як робити.
[англійською] Я одразу злякалася:
збиралася вкласти туди всі свої гроші
[англійською] і потім зовсім не мати покупців,
але з часом все запрацювало.
[англійською] Я досі не знаю, де я буду,
але тішуся, що маю стільки покупців щодня.
[англійською] Вони готують страви іншим африканцям,
[англійською] бо, знаєте, ми не можемо дістати їжу
[англійською] і переважно люди не знають
як готувати наші африканські страви.
[англійською] Тож зазвичай ці страви для хлопців.
Вони воліють купувати страви.
[англійською] Дівчата готують,
потім — продають, а хлопці купують.
[англійською] Коли я хочу якоїсь
нігерійської іжі, я просто йду й пишу:
[англійською] «Хто сьогодні має їжу?»
«Я!» І я купую. Ось і все.
[англійською] Я не хочу себе силувати
готувати щось сам,
[англійською] бо знаєте, на те,
щоб щось приготувати, йдуть години... [сміється]
[англійською] І ще і про продукти треба подбати...
Я не хочу себе силувати!
[англійською] Дехто це робить задля бізнесу,
тож я готовий їх підтримати,
[англійською] й одночасно я теж із того тішуся.
Хай там як — це перемога!
♪ [співає під ритмічну музику] ♪
[англійською] Андрію, яка це версія? Давніша?
[сміється]
— [англійською] До речі, дякую за чай!
— [англійською] Будь ласка.
[англійською] Мій досвід в Україні був «солодко-гіркий».
Україна — чудова країна.
[англійською] І люди тут чудові. Щоправда,
часом можна зустріти й не дуже привітних.
[англійською] Але то життя. Всяке трапляється!
[англійською] Одного разу я сиділа, й одна жіночка
намагалася стягнути мене з мого місця.
[англійською] Ніхто нічого не казав,
дивилися так, ніби нічого й не трапилося.
[англійською] Я не знала,
що робити, і просто дивилася на неї.
[англійською] Я не знаю...
Я не люблю про це говорити, бо часом це боляче.
— [англійською] Вітаю! Добрий день!
— [англійською] Добрий день! Тобто вечір!
[англійською] Я би хотіла дещо вибрати...
[говорять між собою]
Коли я поїхала закордон, я побачила,
як українцям важко там купувати наше молоко,
масло, нашу картоплю, як вони сумують за цим.
Я зрозуміла, що це так само, як ніби іноземці тут —
вони ж теж хочуть свого. Усі їдять українську їжу.
Але всі сумують за своїм. Тому я хотіла частинку Африки привезти їм сюди, в Україну.
Тернопіль — це студентське місто,
і дуже багато іноземців приїжджає.
І марокканці, і нігерійці, і гвінейці, з Кенії...
Багато різних національностей.
Кожен приходить, щось одне своє десь там і знайде.
♪ [співає під ритмічну музику] ♪
[англійською] Назва цієї пісні — «Нічого не хочу».
Ого! [сміється]
[англійською] Це дуже просто, це дуже гарно.
[англійською] Наталя написала цю пісню, а я зробив аранжування.
[англійською] Після того, як я закінчив університет, я зріс [показує рукою], коли почав створювати музику.
[англійською] Отже, немає жодного шансу, що я скажу:
«Ок, я просто хочу повернутися додому та кинути музику».
[англійською] Я щасливий, що я тут.
Я радію, що скористався цією можливістю.
[англійською] Я думаю, моя родина — мої батьки —
підтримують мене й те, як ми працюємо.
[англійською] Я не створюю африканську музику,
чого б їм хотілося.
[англійською] Але я кажу: «Знаєте, я хочу бути
присутнім в Україні. Я тут починав, і це має сенс».
[англійською] Як митець, я відчуваю,
що час від часу добре робити собі ж виклики,
[англійською] представляти аудиторії нові речі,
аби побачити, чи відгукується це їм.
[англійською] Але завжди треба бути націленим на міжнародний рівень.
[англійською] Чесно, я дуже сумую
за домівкою. Дуже сумую!
[англійською] Відтоді, як я приїхав сюди 2013-го року, я був удома лише двічі.
[англійською] Знаєте, я сумую за родиною, за друзями.
[англійською] Сумую за їжею, смачною їжею.
Мені дуже бракує нігерійських страв.
[англійською] Сумую за прогулянками з родиною щонеділі.
[англійською] Ми маємо окрему групу для нігерійської спільноти. І окрему для ганської cпільноти.
[англійською] Але часом ми всі разом
збиралися готувати щось африканське.
[англійською] Ми готуємо африканські страви.
[англійською] Суп егусі… Джолоф з рису ми робимо вже
дуже давно. Раз спробували і відтоді часто готуємо.
[англійською] Перцевий суп, булє, плантан...
[англійською] Багато їжі ми не можемо [приготувати]...
Є багато інгредієнтів, яких нам не дістати.
[англійською] Є одна страва, акара,
її ми готуємо з квасолі, а у вас вона є.
[англійською] Тому це ми можемо замінити і приготувати тут.
[англійською] Мені подобається Україна.
[англійською] Єдине, чому я не почуваюся тут, як удома,
бо й досі всі на мене витріщаються.
[сміється]
[англійською] Я не хотів цього казати, але це реальність!
[англійською] Знаєте, коли ви вдома — там зовсім інакше.
[англійською] Я йду по вулиці, і мене сприймають просто як звичайну людину.
[англійською] Але тут це просто…
Навіть, якщо ти нічим не вирізняєшся...
[англійською] Загалом те, що ти нігерієць чи африканець,
автоматично робить тебе помітним.
[англійською] Я сподіваюся, що люди розумітимуть
одне одного краще, особливо Україну у світі.
[англійською] А я просто пишу музику для всіх.
[англійською] Я пишу музику для всіх.
Не лише для українців, а для всіх.
[англійською] Українцям подобається музика,
їм подобається, які ми люди, і я це ціную.
[англійською] Ще два роки тому я не думав,
що люди такі відкриті, якщо чесно.
[англійською] Чи ні, пробачте, не два роки тому, може, три... може, і чотири-п'ять, як тільки я сюди приїхав.
[англійською] Чесно кажучи, я не думаю, що люди були такі відкриті.
[англійською] Якби я тоді писав таку музику,
як зараз, не знаю, чи був би такий спалах.
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]